في مقطع فيديو لوزير الماليه السوداني
جبريل ابراهيم وضعوا في موقف محرج جدا
خلال الجلسه الافتتاحيه لمجلس الوحده
الاقتصاديه العربيه في الخرطوم امس
نان الفرص والامكانات اللامحدوده
المتاحه في الزراعه والثروه الحيوانيه
وتصنيع الزراعي والبنيه التحتيه المرتبطه
بسلاسل الامداد الغذائيين
يا جماعه
الفضيحه هذه
اخذها الناس
[موسيقى]
المقطع هو حديث الناس في السودان الساعات
الماضيه وخصوصا رده فعل الوزير لمن سواء
سال سؤال ولما قال وات هابيند ولا تعليق
ايه الفضيحه دي واستراد الناس دول فضايح
ما عندهم جنريتر والوزير من بعد ما جات
الكهرباء بعد دقائق معدوده استغل هذه
الفرصه وحاول يتدارك الموقف اللي صار ودعم
المستثمرين اللي حاضرين المجلس الاقتصادي
العربي انه تكون الكهرباء احد القطاعات
المستهدفه للاستثمار خلال المرحله المقبله
لكن حتى هذا النداء محاولات وتبارك الموقف
ما حمى الوزير من الانتقادات والتعليقات
اللي طلبته بسبب الفيديو
على فكره بس للتفكير يعني يبدو انه وزير
الماليه مره محظوظ خلال كلماته والكاميرات
جاهزه دائما تلقط له ردات فعله فمن فتره
كان له مشهد وردت فعل ثانيه صارت برضو
ترند وحتى وقتها تكلمنا عنه خليني اذكركم
فيها
واحد ب60 درجه يسمعني
المربوط الوارد
[موسيقى]